همم الحقيقه احنا دلوقتي الجو في اول يوم
بيحطول عليك ما فيهوش زحمه كتير ناس ههه
لا طولوا براحتكوا بس هو اول يوم ناس
بتفضل اكتر ان هي تفطر في البيت مع الاسره
وكده وبعدين احنا كمان عندنا طقوس يعني
اول يوم ده بيكون في محشي بيكون في بط
بيكون فيه جلاش لحمه مفرومه فالحاجات دي
احنا كمصريين بنفضل اكتر ناكلها من ايد
امهاتنا وجدتنا اكثر من المطاعم فهتلاقي
اول يوم كده الجو هادي خالص والدنيا هو يا
ندى كمان احنا دايما بنعرف ان مصر من
البلدان العربيه لتعد احد ابرز البلدان
العربيه لتظهر عليها مظاهر الاحتفال وطقوس
الاحتفال خصوصا في فتره السحور على كل حال
في موضوع ثاني كمان حابين نسمعه منك الى
جانب الاجواء الرمضانيه قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه الجديد اللي هو محور جدل دائم
خلال السنوات الماضيه شو عم بيصير يا ندى
عندكم
هو فعلا حديث الناس كلها دلوقتي هو قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه الجديد او تعديلات اللي
في قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
المتوقع ان هو يقلل كتير من نسبه الطلاق
في مصر واللي فيه اكتر يعني من
صلاحيات كمان مدينها للقاضي علشان يتدخل
في الحالات السريعه لدعم الاسره علشان
يخاطب جهه العمل بتاعه المطلق ويقدر ان هو
يعرف دخله ويحدد النفقات فيها كتير من
التنظيم كمان بين الطرفين اللي بيتجوزوا
يعني فيها الزام اختار من الزوجه لو هو
هيتجوز على زوجته الاولى فيها
توثيق للطلاق زي ما في توثيق للزواج علشان
برده يقلل شويه من الطلاق الشافعي
والمشاكل اللي بتحصل منه
العقد نفسه بتاع الزواج والطلاق هيكون فيه
شروط تنظم العلاقه علشان الدنيا تكون
واضحه ما بين الزوجين اكثر يمكن حاجه كانت
مثيره للجدل بين الناس وفيها مع وضد هي
منع الاب الرافض لدفع النفقات انه يشوف
ولاده يعني في ناس كانت شايفه انه لا هو
في الاخر ده حق الطفل ان هو يشوف ابوه
سواء بقى هو دفع نفقه او لا او في ناس
كانت شايفه انه طالما الاب مش بيصرف عليهم
فهو فعلا مش من حقه ان هو يشوفهم فده كان
اكتر حاجه مثيره للجدل في القناه